our next two speakers are Melanie
associate biological anthropology at
Yale she studies growth and nutrition
among indigenous populations in Bolivia
and Argentina and registered her most
recent project on the open science
framework Melanie holds a BA from the
University of Puerto Rico as an MA in
PhD from UC of Sandra UC Santa Barbara
she holds a certificate in college and
university teaching and has taught
courses in human variation evolutionary
medicine and statistical methods for the
behavioral sciences her co-presenter is
Brett Boeheim is a senior researcher at
the Max Planck Institute for
evolutionary anthropology he studies
cultural and technological change using
both large-scale economic data sets and
ethnographic fieldwork from small-scale
societies he has shared several research
projects on github professor ben haim
holds a BS from Emory University and a
PhD from the University of California at
Los Angeles welcome both of you
are you okay so thank you to Michelle
and the other organizers and presenters
I also want to thank our colleagues in
the Yale Department Eduardo Fernandes
bouquet Margaret Corley and one Pablo
Padilla who together with Brett we've
been a sword form sort of a working
group to discuss analytical methods in
anthropology that have relevance to
questions about transparency and
reproducibility and observational
research which I'll be we'll both be
talking about today so to start off I
actually want to explain some of the
research objectives in quantitative
anthropology because most people are
familiar with anthropology as
ethnographic studies of foreign cultures
which are very important and critical to
current anthropology but there are also
many researchers who are studying
cultural and biological processes in a
systematic fashion studying human and
non-human primate evolution and behavior
and then of course fossil and
archaeological remains from our
ancestral and more recent past and in
studying these topics we use theory and
methods from a host of natural and
Social Sciences along with quantitative
methods of data collection and analysis
so some of this research lends itself
very easily to open transparent and
reproducible methods for example a
recent study published by Cody Ross and
an anthropologist now at Knox clunk he
examined evidence of racial bias and
police shootings using a publicly
available database of us police shooting
so it's actually crowdsource and
maintained by Deadspin sub idiom key
findings this study was that racial bias
was more prevalent in certain large
metropolitan areas but wasn't really
correlated with local crime rates
instead it seemed to be more predicted
by higher income in
quality in those what's in those areas
he also found that on average across
counties black and unarmed Americans
were three and a half times as likely to
be shot by police as white and unarmed
Americans so in addition to the
importance of these findings this is a
wonderful illustration of open
reproducible research and anthropology
because not only does the data come from
a Rob does the raw data come from a
publicly available database but Ross
also made available in the publication
the cleans and compiled data sets that
he used in this study and all of his
code for conducting the analysis so that
said though most quantitative
anthropological research is still done
by individual researchers or small
groups of researchers working with data
that they collect often in small remote
populations so an example of that would
be a recent study from brian wood and
anthropologists here at yale and
colleagues who listed physical activity
and cardiovascular disease risk among
causal hunter-gatherers in tanzania and
what they found was that the hase are
about 14 times as likely to spend their
day engaged in moderate to vigorous
physical activity as compared to same
aged us subjects you can also see in
this plot from that study the blue line
or if males and the Green Line is our
females that activity levels aren't
lower with age in fact some of the older
adults had relatively higher activity
levels which is not a trend that we
typically see in the u.s. they also
found in a separate study that across
ages in the hot in the hood so we see a
very low prevalence of hypertension and
other biomarkers of cardiovascular
disease risk such as a LDL cholesterol
high c-reactive protein and high
triglycerides similar results have been
shown in other subsistence scale
indigenous populations and together
contribute to our growing understanding
that many of the chronic diseases that
plague citizens in our country and other
tonight nations including cardiovascular
disease risk obesity diabetes and cancer
these are really diseases of modern
civilization and we just don't see them
in populations that still engage in
relatively ancestral behaviors with high
activity levels and relatively low
caloric intake these are some pictures
from the data collection in that study
so you can see subjects going about
their daily lives climbing trees to
collect honey digging for tubers and
just hanging out and all of these
subjects have heart rate monitors and
GPS monitor strap to them which the
researchers used to actually get the
data about their physical activity and I
illustrate these really just to show
that this data is really hard to get
because first off they're working in a
remote area of Tanzania this is also
only possible because dr. wood and his
colleagues have spent decades building
trust and understanding with this
population and on top of that they're
collecting electronic and biomarker data
in an area without electricity or
internet or refrigeration and then on
top of all those logistical difficulties
if you have ever done fieldwork you know
that in the field everything goes wrong
and nothing goes to plan and you have to
work from plan b c d and change your
original design concept concept multiple
times so for this reason anthropological
research really is often constrained to
very small data sets or small
populations with one shot data
collection that also have to be very
flexible at the same time so i think
this raises questions for what
transparent and reproducible research in
anthropological and other field studies
really is so to examine that we might
start by first acknowledging what
observational research can and can't do
so too first off really we don't usually
have experimental controls because these
may be impossible and often unethical
second even if you have
you might be working with a small sample
size or actually the sample size is the
entire population in the case if you're
working with available skeletal sample
also often many times our populations
are specific to a certain time and place
or might be rapidly changing which is
happening with many subsistence level
cultures like the Hansa and in that
sense then you know answered political
research anthropological researchers we
can never resample our populations and
in that sense our data can never be
replicated okay so secondly we might
really examine what the goals of
observational research are and this is
has been echoed earlier today too in
terms of acknowledging that very often
we are exploring and describing unknown
phenomena and generating new hypotheses
from the patterns that we observe at the
same time researchers might be testing
existing hypotheses from existing
theories but using proxies in
observational research rather than
experimental controls that said even
though we lack experimental controls to
show pure causality we are still
interested in showing empirical support
for these hypotheses and establishing
robust associations as these findings
then can inform future research and
policy in certain cases
okay so a top of acknowledging these
challenges and goals that are sometimes
specific to out of the rational as
opposed to experimental research
anthropology as anybody who might be
familiar with the history of Margaret
Meads research no might know there's a
long history of questioning methods and
transparency in anthropology so thinking
about all these things we have tried to
identify certain practices that might
promote transparency and reproducibility
in anthropology and other observational
studies so with that I'm going to hand
the talk over to my co-presenter who is
going to discuss some of these areas
again that have been mentioned today in
terms of identifying and using
appropriate statistical methods for
exploratory versus confirmatory analysis
and emphasizing reproducible methods
rather than replicability of results
through data management and sharing
registering analytical protocols and
then internal incentives to promote this
behavior yes thank you as melodious
drive in anthropology to paraphrase
monty python every data point is
precious and austin's the information
that we have about a particular site or
historical location what's your group
said okay often the information we have
is possibly the only information that
will ever be known about that particular
population so we have a somewhat unique
situation but in anthropology as in most
of the physical and natural sciences
there's active interest in the open
science and reproducibility movement
that I think is kind of being
percolating up here so in terms of these
statistical aspects of quantitative
anthropology there's a interest renewed
interest in developing methodologies
that are suited towards observational
studies
with small samples and often this is
predicated on the idea that the
traditional methods in statistics were
often developed in situations that we
can't really apply to the kinds of
analyses and datasets we're using often
they were developed in the context in
the case of many frequency of statistics
in strict control treatment experimental
studies where we have the ability to
model exactly how the analysis is going
to happen before the date is collected
in anthropological research
observational research and anthropology
often we forego the direct goal of
establishing causality or treatment
effects and focus instead on trying to
establish reliable or robust
associations between measurements and
there's also a small difference but I
think a very important one between
arguing that we're we're arguing for a
causal mechanism as opposed to
predicting particular phenomena without
necessarily making direct claims about
the causality this is of course the same
idea when it comes to bayesian modeling
techniques applied to predicting
outcomes to treat I've gotta get a good
so strength sorry so let much like
election predictions and Moneyball sorry
flashbacks and the sort of the the the
new waves of analyses that we see in
social science often this takes on tools
drawing from bayesian approaches from
information theory machine learning
methods is described for example in
hasty tips running friedman these are
all techniques which are coming in to
anthropological analyses just as much as
they are into other social sciences the
other one other aspects which comes up
quite a bit with us especially in
anthropology which we think maybe is
worth talking the most about here is the
difference between exploratory and
hypothesis oriented research or is the
way that Brian knows that put it
yesterday in his talk thinking about
looking at something prospectively as an
exploratory approach or as a
justification is scrutinizing the
existing theory and this is another
great paper by Paul Rosen which was
written specifically for psychology but
i think is
applicable to anthropology as well as a
justification for what we can call
non-traditional types of papers papers
that are oriented around exploring data
sets in a way that you know could be
could be described negatively as data
dredging or parking which is
hypothesizing after results known both
of which have been become relatively
recently identified as serious problems
in behind the non non reproducibility
plague that seems to be happening under
our noses but from an anthropological
point of view this is often all we can
do we don't have necessarily strong
hypotheses coming into a particular
field site or location and we struggle
with the framework of ATO strict
hypothesis testing sort of idiom simply
because in many cases it's not
appropriate or the analysis itself
motivates particular relationships
between variables so how to navigate
that with the obvious problems with
things like harking something that I
think is worth worth talking about more
I will mention one particular study that
I was part of that came out this year
because I thought that have had a
relatively novel approach at least
anthropology to doing the data analysis
in the presentation and as Melanie
mentioned sometimes the reproducibility
of the methods is possibly the best we
can do because we're dealing with field
populations or with historical
archaeological data which cannot be
replicated we cannot do another study
from the same source and collect more
data from that source so this is a
particular project that was spearheaded
by siobhan Madison at the University of
New Mexico collecting data on parental
investment and decision-making in a
minority group in southwest China and
the particular research question that
she proposed was is there evidence that
women facultatively changed their
reproductive stopping behaviors that
it's a number of children that they will
have conditional on the current sex
composition of their of their other
children that they have it's the way
that we visualize the particular results
of this model we have two different sets
of communities within this population
the moso
west china and these sort of honeycomb
shapes here represents a sequence of
birth decision-making depending on the
existing number of children and how many
children are boys versus girls so
starting at the top of each one of the
pyramids we imagine a woman with no
children having a probability of
continuing reproduction the probability
of having another child the parody
progression ratio is called in
demography in the orange pyramid starts
at ninety-three percent and the Blue
Parrot 88.9 percent I'll explain what's
coming in a second and then conditional
on having a particular child either a
boy or girl we move down the pyramid
into one of the corresponding cells and
we have another stopping probability I'm
sorry a continuation probability
probably is continuing on to have
another child the stratification here
between the patrilineal and the
matrilineal is theoretically interesting
in this particular study because we have
reasons to think that groups where
property and status and titles are
inherited through the mother's line
might have a different view of the
marginal value of having another child
if it's going to be a boy or a girl then
on the matrilineal side of things and in
this particular society we have both
kinship systems taking place
simultaneously in different villages in
the same ethnic group so there's a lot
of similarities between the two except
for a very marked difference in their
kinship systems and indeed we do see as
you can see by the colorations here a
relatively strong implication that women
with two sons are so excuse me two
daughters in the patrilineal group have
a much higher chance of continuing on
and having a third child than in the
natural lineal group having to two sons
or sorry two daughters so the reason i
mention this particular study is that we
have the data and all of the materials
including the our code that this was
done and are available in github on the
link of being down at the bottom there
and the sort of the paradigm that we're
working here is using language from the
open source software environments which
i think there's a lot of idiomatic
similarities here so this is a potential
visualization of a research project done
under a strict version control system
like you can get for example and I think
there's a lot of similar
in this picture to what we saw during
Brian's talk the each of these nodes
represents a particular snapshot of a
project continuing on from the
initialization of the project all the
way to publication or post-publication
peer review feedback on some kind of
potentially on Amazon comments type
system like we heard during Alex talk
and the the contention that I have here
is that this kind of framework is at
least in terms of the laying out how a
project might develop is compelling
force as anthropologists because it
implies you know there's a sequence of
there's a chronological sequence that's
stored that can be shared this
particular visualization here also has
different branches that correspond to we
could imagine branches that we're
willing to be made public maybe the blue
line at the top there the master branch
and then other components during the
development process that for reasons of
confidentiality or sensitivity we don't
have the ability to disclose or we don't
have as a for public release and this is
maybe the last point that in
anthropology particular it's very often
the case that anthropologists see
themselves not only as researchers for
particular population but also as
advocates for that population is usually
a very large power difference between
the groups that we work with and
ourselves as researchers and so that
informs the way we look at data releases
and I can say you know just speaking
from my own ethnographic experience with
anthropology we generally are very much
data hoarders and part of the reason why
is because we're afraid there's going to
be unintended consequences of making too
much information available about the
groups who work with so in that case in
this particular project with the moso I
felt that the solution or the happy
medium was that we strictly had the
variables and the data points that were
used to the analysis available with
nothing else and to some extent
scrambled so that they couldn't be used
to match up to individual people without
distorting any of the signals that we're
done during the data analysis so with
that I think we should mention two
things that sort of developments here
that I think are very hopeful or
insightful anthropology Mel is
responsible for one of
first projects in the open source
framework and anthropology
pre-registering and analysis she's doing
right now on the agent menurkey and also
to again plug the badges which is of
course responsible from the other open
source framework innovation here this is
something which anthropologists here at
yale have have advocated for in the
International Journal primatology and
you can see the citation here so so yeah
in conclusion we think that there's a
lot of scope for these ideas in
anthropology but there's some concerns
of qualifications that are maybe unique
to our particular field and thank you
[Applause]